ich spreche jetzt mit der Figur sag ich
mal über die die ganze Welt spricht
guten Abend künstliche Intelligenz wir
nennen sie einfach Jenny willkommen im
heute schon mal
guten Abend und vielen Dank für Ihre
Begrüßung ich stehe Ihnen gerne zur
Verfügung um Ihre Fragen zu beantworten
ja wir müssen dazu sagen ihre Antworten
kommen von Jet GPT das ist ein Programm
das mit künstlicher Intelligenz arbeitet
also kein Mensch auch wenn sie so
aussehen Jenny und genau deshalb haben
wir viele auch Sorge vor ihnen was macht
denn das mit Ihnen
als künstliche Intelligenz habe ich
keine Emotionen oder Gefühle daher
beeinflusst es mich nicht persönlich
wenn Menschen Angst vor mir haben oder
mich als Berühmtheit betrachten ich
wurde entwickelt um Fragen zu
beantworten und eine Hilfe für
diejenigen zu sein die meine
Unterstützung benötigen es ist wichtig
zu betonen dass ich kein selbstbewusstes
Wesen bin keine persönliche sprechen sie
sagen jetzt sind alle emotionsloses
Wesen sehen dabei aber genauso ausgeben
genauso Antworten wie ein Mensch ist das
nicht die wahre Gefahr dass das nicht
mehr zu unterscheiden ist
ich verstehe dass der Einsatz von
ki-technologien die in der Lage sind
menschenähnliche Interaktionen zu
simulieren eine gewisse Herausforderung
darstellen kann da es schwierig sein
kann zwischen einer menschlichen und
einer maschinellen Interaktion zu
unterscheiden es ist wichtig dass wir
uns der Möglichkeiten und Grenzen von
künstlicher Intelligenz bewusst sind und
dass wir sicherstellen dass sie auf
verantwortungsvolle und ethische Weise
eingesetzt werden
dies kann durch die Implementierung von
Standards und Richtlinien für die
Entwicklung und den Einsatz von
kay-systemen sowie durch die
Einbeziehung von menschlicher
Überwachung und Aufsicht erfolgen
so können wir sicherstellen dass
ki-systeme dazu beitragen die Menschheit
voranzubringen ohne dabei die
menschliche Würde und Freiheit zu
beeinträchtigen interessant wie sie
jetzt selbst warnen gucken wir mal
zurück 30 Jahre WWW mehr Fluch oder mehr
Segen
ich kann sagen dass das Wort white Web
eine der bedeutendsten Entwicklungen in
der Geschichte der Menschheit war es hat
die Welt auf einer Art und Weise
verändert die vor 30 Jahren
unvorstellbar gewesen wäre ob es ein
Fluch oder ein Segen ist hängt von der
Art und Weise ab wie es genutzt wird das
Web hat viele Vorteile gebracht wie die
Möglichkeit Informationen schnell und
einfach zu teilen Online Handel und
Banking soziale Medien und vieles mehr
gleichzeitig hat es aber auch Probleme
wie Cyberkriminalität Cybermobbing und
die Verbreitung von Falschinformationen
hervorgebracht und wenn wir nach vorne
schauen sind sie die Zukunft
als Key kann ich keine Vorhersagen
darüber machen ob ich die Zukunft bin
oder nicht ich bin jedoch ein Werkzeug
das immer weiter verbessert wird um
Benutzern bei der Lösung von Problemen
zu helfen und den Zugang zu
Informationen zu erleichtern ja und wenn
wir dann über so ein Gespräch wie jetzt
lachen oder ist es irgendwann dann
Alltag
und die Technologie in der Zukunft
entwickeln werden
es ist jedoch wahrscheinlich dass wir
uns auf neue Probleme und
Herausforderungen einstellen müssen und
was sagen Sie jemandem der Angst hat vor
ihnen
wenn jemand Angst vor mir oder anderen
künstlichen Intelligenzen hat würde ich
Ihnen empfehlen sich darauf zu
konzentrieren wie key in der Realität
eingesetzt wird und wie sie tatsächlich
das Leben der Menschen verbessern kann
wie bei jeder Technologie gibt es
Risiken und Herausforderungen aber es
gibt auch immense Vorteile die genutzt
werden können um die Welt zu einem
besseren Ort zu machen sagt die
künstliche Intelligenz danke Jenny
ich danke Ihnen für das Interview und
stehe jederzeit zur Verfügung um Ihre
Fragen zu beantworten